you both have talked very candidly it's
a very famous story
infidelity in the marriage and how you
navigated that that time never there's
never been infidelity in our marriage
never been infidelity never will smith
is shutting down speculation surrounding
his marriage with jada pinkett smith
what is the secret to getting it right
for you two because i know you worked
hard at marriage we've been asking
ourselves that question and
really at the end of the day
it's
just not quitting you know while
chatting with gayle king on cbs sunday
morning the oscar nominee clears up
rumors of infidelity within his
relationship the couple's decades-long
marriage has become a hot topic since
this 2020 red table talk interview where
jada revealed her quote entanglement
with singer august alcina it was a
relationship absolutely i was in a lot
of pain and i was very broken
now in the process of that relationship
i definitely realized that
you can't find happiness outside of
yourself after revealing that rumors
swirled that jada had an affair but will
is shutting that claim down there's
never been infidelity in our marriage
never been in fidelity never
jada and i
talk about everything
and we have never surprised one another
with anything ever and turns out all
that talk surrounding will's personal
life doesn't bother will he's even
turned it into a positive i have decided
that chatter
about my life
can be of a benefit
to people i think the chatter is a
really
uh chatter chatter is the first stage to
uh having a real conversation and being
able to truly explore
if
some of the things in your heart are
loving or poisonous this candid moment
comes as no surprise will and jada have
always been super transparent about
their ups and downs as a married couple
back in september while discussing his
memoir will to gq the philadelphia
native revealed that jada wasn't the
only one engaging in relationships
outside of their marriage
we'll explain to the mag in part quote
jada never believed in conventional
marriage
but the experience is that the freedoms
that we've given one another and the
unconditional support to me is the
highest definition of love anything that
i need to make myself happy
i will present that to my wife that i
need that to be happy divorce is not an
option we going to be together so we're
going to figure out how to be happy fast
forward to 2022 and it seems all's well
with a pair who've been attending
numerous events together
celebrating will's latest role in king
richard you just went toe-to-toe
for two
with the number one player in the whole
world had her shook
if you don't have no respect for
yourself right now
you will never have none that's will
playing richard williams the dad of
tennis champs venus and serena he's
already nabbed the golden globe and sag
award and up next he's going for oscar
gold i'm just super proud of him i'm
super super proud of him e.t caught up
with the pair last month at the sag
awards where they accidentally matched
and jada couldn't help but gush over her
hubby's success
first time you saw it what was your
oh i was just so proud i mean we had so
many conversations about it and he was
very nervous you know what i mean um but
just for him to have the opportunity to
highlight such a
beautiful black family that really
struggled
and through their struggles
made something very beautiful you know
what i mean so we found it really
inspiring and i'm just super proud of
them
[Music]